I bought this for laundry because,
you know, there's a million kids.
We got a lot of laundry. Here's what I'm thinking, though.
For Christmas, I always give my kids a gift from Santa.
And Santa does not give them the big fucking gift,
because fuck that. I get the glory,
not Santa. I give them the big gift.
Santa gives them some little shit that they like.
The tinker toys and shit. So there's four kids,
and the kids always talk about board games and shit.
I feel like I could fill this with a bunch of,
like, board games and blankets and slippers.
Like, cute shit for the kids.
And just be their big Christmas gift for the kids.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Don't you think that's a really cute idea?
That's what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna use it for laundry.